je me souviens surtout de sa curiosité à
propos de tout ce qui concernait la
martinique aimé césaire à la mort de mon
père a écrit tout ce qui est
martiniquais était le sien bien entendu
ça concerne les sciences du vivant
puisque c'était son métier
mon père était très féru en termes de
botanique comme joséphine la veille
était d'ailleurs dans le domaine du
développement économique
robert rosen a été visionnée aussi dès
les années 50 il avait compris que la
monoculture de la canne ne suffirait pas
à nourrir la martinique et que le
tourisme constitue est un axe de
développement majeur
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles il
s'est tellement battu pour que le site
de la pagerie ne meurt pas
[Musique]
m
mon père était un homme animé de
passions diverses vous l'aurez compris
mais d'abord patients de la rencontre
rencontre avec les savons mais rencontre
partage d'informations de connaissances
avec tous les curieux aussi modeste
soit-il ce qu'il est mais ce qui est la
convergence avec les autres chefs des
renseignements ou qui pouvaient les
apporter des renseignements et sur la
terrasse de la brasserie de 13 étages
conversation avait quelquefois dû avec
tous ceux qui passaient aidé et qui
désiraient le connaître
[Musique]
la pagerie est un lieu de rencontre est
d'abord de rencontre avec la nature
ce domaine a été comme la martinique
tout entière dès le xviiie siècle ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui un haut lieu
de la biodiversité